a seven-hour drive from Denver's airport
deep in the jagged peaks of Colorado San
Juan mountain range lies the most unique
an extreme ski area in the country just
because you're skiing in a ski area does
not mean that you're safe there's
nothing safe about what we're doing
today
this is Silverton Mountain in 2002
husband and wife team aaron and jen
brill got $100,000 state loan and sunk
their savings into a dream yeah to build
a ski resort like no other in America at
the time I was a sponsored snowboarder
on a b-level and I was sponsored by Clif
Bar so we ate a lot of Clif bars to get
through at that time they signed a
40-year lease with the Bureau of Land
Management for a spectacular piece of
property and bought a used Cheerilee
from the 1970s when it opened it was
Colorado's first new ski area in 20
years today
it is one-of-a-kind a ski area with the
expert only dream we just saw there was
a void in the ski market everybody was
focusing on trying to be mini Disney
Land
and we were thinking that that's just
the hardcore skiers or snowboarders that
we were being left out
most Ski Areas in Colorado are massive
into playgrounds Vail Resorts one of the
largest ski companies in the country
that's ten mountains hotels restaurants
and lots of operate if ''tis but you
won't find swanky fireside lounges or
gourmet restaurants at Silverton there's
a tent at the base an outhouse and an
old broken-down flat ski rental shop
there's not even running water so this
is nothing like any other ski resort
I've ever been to
one of the risks our business model is
that it's totally reliant on the quality
of this be experienced luckily we're in
one of the snowiest places in the United
States so here's how it works you start
the day out by getting your avalanche
gear they teach you how it works I'm
wearing a beacon right now I have a
shovel I have a probe you also have to
sign your life away I mean the waiver is
very clear you could die here today you
take this one chair lift up and then you
either hike or you can purchase a
helicopter drop Silverton has only open
four days a week during the winter
months and only 80 skiers are allowed in
the mountain every day
how many skier visits did you guys have
thousands what we see in a year is what
you know of Breckenridge or Vail sees on
a busy holiday day the brill's make just
a fraction of what the big resorts do it
took them six years to earn a profit but
there are no plans to supersize
Silverton instead they're growing their
business by offering their mountain out
for $8,000 private parties and by adding
more heli skiing options out of the 10
million skiers in the United States how
many of those skiers are good enough for
your Mountain here most people that ski
probably aren't good enough to ski it's
over tonight however a lot of people can
do things that they had no idea that
they could ever do they just need
somebody to show them how it can be done